(upbeat playful music)
- Aladdin and Little Mermaid.
Poor Ariel.
I see where you're going
with this and it's not nice.
(upbeat music)
I'm gonna do Lion King, Princess and Frog.
I don't know Big Hero 6,
so I'm gonna do Tangled.
Here I'm gonna do Moana for sure.
Aladdin for sure.
Mermaid.
I'll do Mulan, Nightmare Before.
This side.
(laughs)
Up, so good.
Toy Story,
Coco.
Woo, yikes!
Okay, Bug's Life.
(laughs)
Finding Nemo, Monsters, Inc.
And I'll definitely do The Incredibles.
Okay, now it's getting tough.
Lion King here.
Moana.
Oh, it's hard!
This one's not nice.
Those are two of my favorites.
Oh that's sad.
I gotta come back to that one.
And this one I'll do Nightmare.
Incredibles, Nemo.
Wow, ugh.
Toy Story 3 here.
Up.
Huh, Aladdin and Little Mermaid.
Aladdin and Little Mermaid.
(laughs)
- I'm gonna go Aladdin.
Poor Ariel.
For me personally, I'm gonna go Up here.
I'm gonna go The Incredibles.
Wow, I see where you're going
with this and it's not nice.
It's not right to make people do this.
Okay so this I would also go Aladdin.
And of the two I would still go Lion King.
Wow, wow!
I'm gonna go Up.
So now I'm at Lion King and Up.
I did it.
(gentle music)
It was so moving.
Everybody knows those first
10 minutes of that movie
are like shocking, you know what I mean?
The fact that they get you so invested
in those characters so quickly
that you completely are devastated
when one of them is dead.
(exhales)
It's very emotional.
I think I had seen it too when
I had just gotten married.
I hadn't been married for very long
so it was a very
difficult decision for me.
I'm broken up about it.
I'm hurt that I had to choose.
I blame these people.
They made me make the choice.
I would never have made the,
we don't live in a world
where you have to choose
between these two things.
These people have designed
this awful thing for us to do.
Blame Business Insider.
You send your hate tweets to them, not me.